hallo herzlich willkommen zur pimp my
kitchen in meinem format geht es darum
menschen mit einer neuen küche zu
überraschen oder deren alte küche
aufzupumpen
[Musik]
in der ersten folge habe ich eine ganz
neue küche geplant und zwar habe ich
damit dennoch überrascht hat sich auch
wirklich wahnsinnig über die küche
gefreut und sie wurde auch richtig
richtig schön ihr könnt euch gerne die
erste folge mal anschauen in der
heutigen folge möchte ich einen menschen
überraschen der auch ganz besonders ist
und den ihr wahrscheinlich fast alle
kennt er ist rapper er ist unternehmer
er ist doch ziemlich lustig und er ist
der könig von deutschland es ist eko
fresh und eco wohnt mit seiner frau
sarah in der nähe von köln sie haben
gerade ein haus gebaut richten das
momentan ein und als ich das gehört habe
habe ich mir gedacht eco sarah euch
überraschen ich mit einer neuen küche so
ein bisschen kenne ich ja sager sie
waren ja auch schon da aber ich möchte
natürlich auch wissen was gefällt ihnen
was gefällt ihnen gar nicht sehen wie
sie jetzt gerade leben was ihnen in der
aktuellen wohnung gefällt und was ihnen
gar nicht gefällt und vor allem möchte
ich noch ein paar insider das heißt ich
befrage auch die freunde die familie
vielleicht paar bekannte oder nachbarn
je nachdem wie eben gerade da ist und
möchte einfach herausfinden wie möchte
familie borer die neue küche haben also
gehen wir nach köln ich freue mich
[Musik]
jetzt sind wir dabei den boris und ich
bin schon richtig gespannt darauf die
küche kenne ich ja schon so ein bisschen
aus stories aus dem internet aber ich
bin gespannt drauf denn in wirklichkeit
sieht oft anders aus und dann schauen
wir mal was der wird den beiden gefällt
und was ihnen so gar nicht gefällt
es richtig glauben
[Musik]
besser ein
das ist hier hause fresh hier ist unser
bruder da ist auch schon das objekt der
begierde oder vielleicht nicht nämlich
unsere küche
[Musik]
die saga kommt ja auch die kocht er sehr
gerne auf und ist für instagram zum
beispiel so gesunde sachen und soja und
deswegen kann sie wahrscheinlich am
besten darüber erzählen wie das so ist
ich kenne die roben paar sachen
ab und zu schaut mit
dem größten teil übernimmst du natürlich
genau also ich versuche eigentlich jeden
tag frisch zu kochen das fängt morgens
beim frühstück an dann gibt es müsli
smoothies und all den kram ja und
nachmittag zieht sich das eigentlich
weiter also hab da so meinen mein
kleines repertoire an rezepten und
eigentlich kochen wir schon sehr viel
und auch frisch und auch ergiebig
eigentlich ja wenn ich jetzt die küche
antwort die sie doch voll modernen außen
schön und schön auf hochglanz aber ich
weiß auch was hochglanz für nachteile
mit sich bringt jetzt wenn sich der
gründer
super stylische geräte hier sind es
lampen oder ist es das sind lampen
dunstabzugshauben also kannst du dir
vorstellen wie oft ich natürlich auch
putzen muss damit das auch so schön
glänzt ok dann lasst uns doch einmal so
durch die küche gehen und du sagst mir
vielleicht erst mal machen wir es mal
das schlechte so was dir nicht so gut
gefällt was du auf jeden fall geändert
haben willst wo du sagst durch das regt
mich jeden tag auf und dann was dir
vielleicht gut gefällt und was wir
übernehmen können
liebes
und zwar kommen würde hier
stets seiner frau oder unsere katze aber
das muss ja das findet hier statt in der
küche es ist nicht ganz ideal muss ich
aber wisst ihr was ihr könnt euch das
genau angucken
diese soll jedes kamel dagegen meine
kerze ich
verspreche wir kriegen etwas mit der
katze kriegen wir hin für euch beide
dass das sie sagt meine katze hat den
besten platz und du sagst ok ich muss
nicht unbedingt sein
ja du anfangs haben wir ja überlegt die
tatsächlich mitzunehmen aber die neue
küche oder der raum der neuen küche ist
halt ganz anders gestaltet das heißt vom
vom grundsatz passt die gar nicht rein
und ich freue mich die aber dem
nachmieter übergeben zu können und freue
mich natürlich auch wenn die neue küche
ja so ein bisschen angepasste an unserem
dem er gehen also darf man danke freut
sich bestimmt anderes und dann machen
wir jetzt eine küche die euren
bedürfnissen entspricht ich liebe ja die
kochen soll ja aber das finde ich echt
ist ist ein traum wie hier aber mir
fehlen hier zum beispiel die steckdosen
das heißt ich habe hier irgendwie kein
platz zum arbeiten sondern muss für
ihren genau muss halt immer irgendwie
umswitchen weil die vordere fläche ist
halt so kaum genutzter fläche sonst
müsste ich halt immer irgendwie umgehen
und ja das würde ich tatsächlich dann in
der küche anders machen ok so hier
wunderschön zusammen gewürfelt von a bis
z eigentlich ja also grundordnung ist ja
so halperin aber weißt du wenn du keinen
platz hast und nicht von anfang an der
ordnung dann haushalt einfach irgendwie
rein am eifer des gefechts normal wenn
du nicht alleine wo unsere gärtner und
vielleicht das kind noch mit hilft dann
steht immer in ordnung wie sieht's bei
euch aus dem kühlschrank das
wahrscheinlich hier ist wahrscheinlich
zu klein der ist zu klein also wir haben
hier oben haben wir
haben wir die ganze
sache natürlich drin unten haben wir
gefrierschrank aber wir merken immer
wieder weil wir halt auch wirklich
frisch kochen wir haben sehr viel obst
und gemüse das ist einfach vom platz
viel zu wenig ist ja also es ist zwar
schade weil es eigentlich schön
integriert ist aber ich sag mal für für
unsere koch bedürfnisse hast du schon
das doppeltes ja doch jemand friert ja
auch mal eine mit kindern dann kocht
suppe und dann fährst du dass ein höhe
für den nächsten tag und da haben wir
halt echt wenig platz und wie sieht's
mit ihr unter der spüle ja sage ich dir
das grauen also der müll der der müll
ist da ist es ist okay aber das problem
ist halt wirklich die ecke der raum ist
voll aber du kommst halt gar nicht
gefühlt dann haben und auch die
ungenutzte ecke daun das eigentlich oder
stoff den man gut hätte in dieser küche
gebrauchen können ja vielleicht befinden
würde auch dann eine lösung gut und da
ist wahrscheinlich die spülmaschine
genau das heißt wir gucken nach einem
guten mülltrennen system für
reinigungsmittel vielleicht ein bisschen
unzugänglicher für kinder ja okay wenn
man am waschbecken sind wissen bei euch
so der wasserkonsum also was trinkt ihr
trinkt ihr stilles wasser oder
sportliches wir trinken tatsächlich
unterschiedlich weil ingo trinkt super
gerne stilles wasser und ich trinke er
sprudelwasser ok und ihr seid dann immer
so fleißig am kistenschleppen
rundschau dem 1
habt ihr in eurem neuen haus eine
enthärtungsanlage ja also wir haben
darauf geachtet okay war da können wir
zum beispiel am waschbecken direkt dann
was einbauen was model was herauskommt
und wenn ja was sowieso gefiltert ist
also kein geld mehr hat dann könnte das
leitungswasser trinken so machen wir so
ein leitungswasser ist ja eigentlich das
beste kontrollierte wasser hier bei uns
in deutschland und dann könntet ihr
praktisch da brauchte ich kein platz
mehr für kisten nämlich nicht mit
fremden kein leergut mehr sammeln und
könnt aus dem wasserhahn sprudelwasser
oder stilles wasser dann einfach zapfen
das risiko und eco freut sich der muss
dann eben nicht mehr
nossen schleppen und fand weg bringen ja
ok super
[Musik]
und im prinzip wollt ihr eine moderne
küche es soll gemütlich sein platz für
alle möglichen geräte haben gesunde
küche ist bei dir ein großes thema genau
also wir kochen gesund hier ist jetzt
das problem tatsächlich habe nicht viel
platz für gewürze basilikum was diese
ganzen frisch gehen also das ist wichtig
weil eco achtet ja mittlerweile auch auf
seiner liege auf seine linie er fängt er
bald an film zu drehen und dann brauche
ich ganz ganz viel material ok wärst du
immer der sagen wir durch frische
kräuter würde ich auch züchten könnte
unbedingt dann gibt's ja sogar auch
sprossen die man halt so was ja
definitiv erklären bestes beispiel ich
musste mir tatsächlich jetzt
kräuter heute suchen weil ich habe es
tatsächlich am anfang hier stehen
allerdings dadurch dass hier einfach
kein licht reinkommt city mir komplett
eingegangen und da hast du recht auf
kunstblumen umgestellt damit so er okay
ein bisschen grünes leben hier in der
küche haben also ist total schade weil
ich hier nirgends so die möglichkeit
habe eigentlich weißt du sowas zu orten
oder das anzurichten oder zu benutzen ja
ich weiß von einem stories dass er auch
oft müsli ist und porree hat er
wahrscheinlich auch 80 verschiedene
geöffnet leser innen und gläser und die
willst du bestimmt auch
bestaunen ok ja genau also hier ist
alles komplett
von nüssen bis haferflocken bis alles
mögliche eigentlich und es ist schade
weil mittlerweile stapel ich halte schon
alles drauf und man erkennt hat von oben
auch gar nicht was es ist ich denke dass
ein etikett ihr geld
überall dann wollen wir uns vielleicht
kurz die baustelle anschauen ja das wäre
dass ich so einen groben überblick habe
wie die küche aussieht denn gebaut ist
das haus schon ist es im rohbau genau
und dann kann ich mir überlegen wie wir
die küche wir sind gespannt ja liebe
sally herzlich willkommen hier in
unserem rohbau und wie du siehst kannst
du direkt aus der tür eine wichtigsten
raum eigentlich weil da wird dir das
ganze leben stattfinden so gesehen habe
ich die kirche wir sind so aufgeregt wie
du siehst ist unser erstes haus ist
unser großes projekt in unserem leben ja
die leute
hier der sinken oder so das ist für uns
eine ganz große sache in unseren leben
und wir sind froh dass wir das machen
und ich denke dass wir hier euch das
anguckt und ein schutz gibt es nicht
schön und so ein haushalt schon
gemütlichkeit reinbringen funktionalität
deshalb schon immer so eines der
wichtigsten dinge immer wieder oder
donald werden und man plant ihr euren
die zukunft ja das ist schon das kriegen
wir hin
jetzt habt ihr euch schon ein bild von
sarah und etwas machen können aber ich
möchte jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr
erfahren und dazu habe ich jetzt freunde
und familie eingeladen und treffe mich
mit denen im café in kerpen denn da
können wir uns in ruhe unterhalten
ja wir sind jetzt hat den captain und
zwar im themen sebastians ist ein
richtig schönes café hat uns empfohlen
und jetzt kriegen wir hier noch kurzen
kaffee ich habe auch gesehen die russen
hier den kaffee selber und ich nehme ein
paar kaffeebohnen für die küche mit
dürftig mit der einen cappuccino
hardcover mit ja und ich würde gerne ich
habe da gesehen ihr habt selbst
gerösteten kaffee würde ich gerne
gute wahl
leider ok etwas natürlich perfekt
da in der kinderecke da ist jemand den
ich kenne geht man mit
bonn
[Musik]
hallo
ja wir trinken ja gerade kaffee was
machst du hier ach so ich lese hier am
wochenende immer ein bisschen was muss
ja auch irgendwie an infos kommen
für ihn die kenne ich ja die mache ich
das gerne mit dem ich zur schule
gegangen ich lust habe man auch ja er
war zwei klassen über mir wir werden
zusammen gymnasium
ja ich mache jetzt die küche für ihn und
braucht noch ein bisschen android für
deko einrichtungen also was ich weiß ist
ja lyrisch sehr versiert dh das kommt ja
vom gymnasium jetzt sehr klug auch hier
als dann ist irgendwas was smart smart
zu sachen in die küche ist klar ich
mache zum beispiel ein connected ist
auch connected ja weil die
mönchengladbach connection man kennt uns
beide genau daher und der beste freund
warst du weißt das noch nicht aber ich
erzähle
ihm zusammen
ziemlich braucht
ich informiere mich immer weiter
über super tiere
wusstest du dass das irische team
der fast zwei meter lang ist nicht wahr
ich höre
nein du musst los
ja ich muss dir küche fertig machen ok
ich bleibe dann hier also falls nämlich
noch raus sagt bescheid
viel spaß danke liebe stellgröße bitte
beeindruckend der sibirische tiger
das ist ein gerät
[Musik]
dazu thomas
kommen sie
wir haben uns auch ein bauking gelernt
also noch gar nicht so lange aber
tatsächlich sehr enges miteinander weil
ich von ja von der pike an mit dabei
will beim hausbau
jako kenne ich seit 15 jahren und sarah
seitdem sie mit ihm zusammen ist und
kenne ich
kennengelernt habe ich ihn hatte in
einer 35 bereitete wohnung gelebt und
wie sag ich mal eine küche also die
schüler wichtiger als wohnzimmer oder
den eco kenne ich auch seit 15 jahren
ungefähr trend auch in gremberg
aufgewachsen
[Musik]
so klien und auf jeden fall mit so golde
silbertönen wenn es dann um ihnen den
wohn und essbereich geht er aber auch
viele bar aus
ich sage canon modell
ich glaube eco ist es nicht so wichtig
ist er
zurückhaltend oder bescheiden aber in
form des pärchens wird das glaube ich
moderne also ich glaube wo deren auf
jeden fall aber die sache hat sich auch
so ein bisschen entwickelt dann im stil
ist ja auch normal wie ich schon
manchmal auch auf jeden fall modern aber
auch ein bisschen klassisch war also
nicht so dieses typische was ihr heute
ist so anthrazit weiß ist ja sehr
typisch dass man dann von außen aber
dass man das dann ein bisschen aufpeppen
mit den flächen der antiken möbelstück
oder was farbe rein bringt das ist eine
gute mischung ist
suckow
frühstück kann gut kochen also nicht
dass er schlecht kocht aber dass er sah
was bringt also ich glaube dass die
sarah schon immer auf ernährung geachtet
hat er sehr wichtig was sie ist also
dass es gesund ist aber auch gut
schmeckt erklärt den eco da so ein
bisschen das auch mit beigebracht dass
studie hatte dafür überhaupt keinen plan
gehabt
sarah ist er da so ein bisschen
gewachsen und ich glaube dass vom stil
her
auch der sarah wichtig funktionell
natürlich aber das ist auch sehr schön
aussieht also dass sie auch gerne wenn
jemand reinkommt und sagt wow was hast
du für eine tolle küche die man sehr mag
das nicht welche frauen
jetzt habe ich ja schon einige infos mit
denen ich arbeiten kann die küche der
familie borer ist etwa sechs mal vier
meter groß an allen vier seiten hat sie
eine unterbrechung zur einen seite geht
man direkt ins esszimmer auf der anderen
seite ist der durchgang zum flur also
zum eingangsbereich des hauses die
vordere seite hat eine fensterfront die
dann eben zur straßenseite rausschaut
und auf der vierten seite ist praktisch
der durchgang zur terrasse wo man eben
auch nach draußen kommt in den
außenbereich ins haus werden einziehen
drei personen plus kater und ich habe
mir jetzt gedacht die familie die kocht
viel frisch gerne auch mal für videos
drews das heißt es müssen offener schöne
einladende küche sein sie ernähren sich
sehr gesund und sie brauchen viel platz
für frisches optisch gesehen sollte die
küche relativ modern sein stylisch aber
trotzdem praktisch und funktional so ein
bisschen street und vielleicht auch
rapper tauglich und jetzt werde ich erst
einmal schauen welche geräte ich dafür
noch aussuchen
[Musik]
für die küchenplanung nehmt ihr euch am
besten wirklich fehlt seit auch bei uns
wird seit nämlich echt spät ich bin
jetzt gerade noch dran und suchen noch
die geräte aus ich suche noch den wasser
platz aus und einfach noch so ein
bisschen die innenausstattung ich habe
mir jetzt hier schon überlegt dass ich
gerade das thema dunstabzugshaube
thematisieren möchte denn der dunstabzug
jetzt in der aktuellen küche des cs
katastrophe den könig lassen der hang
total im gesicht also muss auf jeden
fall eindecken lüfter her und damit der
aber auch was bringt ich hab da nämlich
war es im hinterkopf wir waren nämlich
auf der ifa in berlin und dort habe ich
den neuen becken lüfter von bosch
gesehen er hängt an der decke und fährt
dann automatisch herunter und den werde
ich auf jeden fall bestellen da ist da
ist wirklich der hammer dann auf jeden
fall auch noch eine große kühl und
gefrierkombination also kühlschrank mit
kühlfach am besten sogar zwei dann sieht
es nämlich aus wie so ein side by side
kühlschrank richtig viel platz kann ich
übrigens auch im haus sparen wenn ich
bei der blancco unit eine armatur
verwende bei der direct heißes wasser
raus kommt also die trinker so kann man
sich den wasserkocher zum beispiel
sparen und dann werde ich noch die
drinks oder integrieren denn dann spart
man sich die ganzen wasserkästen und
getränkevorräte man kann dann nämlich am
wasserhahn kaltes gefiltertes wasser
raus lassen sprudel still oder medium
und auf der anderen seite eben dieses
trinkt das heißt heißes wasser auf
knopfdruck und dann habe ich beides auf
der armatur beziehungsweise an der
jugend integriert und spar ganz viel
vorrats platz und damit die kirche von
innen auch gut ausgestattet ist schaue
ich jetzt hier noch bei kesseböhmer
vorbei dem nämlich ganz clevere systeme
zum einen werde ich die turn motion auf
jeden fall mit integrieren das ist so
ein dreh schrank den ich praktisch ihren
ganz normalen vorratsschrank integriere
ich habe den space flex sowieso immer
bei mir also den habe ich immer auf
vorrat den kann man nämlich überall
integrieren und überall tolle dinge
verstauen und vor allem schön ordentlich
verstaut und was dort auch ganz gut ist
ich werde auf jeden fall meinen
lieblings schrank integrieren das ist
nämlich der tandem das ist der bug
schrank den ich zu hause auch bei mir
habe und da passen auch ganz viele
vorräte rhein
findet konkrete planung werde ich mir
jetzt erstmal der küchenausstellung bei
nobilia entfernt anschauen da solltet
ihr euch am besten im vorfeld schon
überlegen was ihr möchtet geht mit eurem
partner dahin schaut euch am besten
vorher schon an welche küche gefällt mir
wie groß muss die küche sein welche
funktionen soll sie beinhalten ihr habt
dann vor ort die zeit und es erspart
euch echt ein bisschen arbeit vielleicht
ein bisschen streit war weiß direkt was
man möchte und trotzdem könnt ihr euch
ja vor ort ein bisschen inspirieren
lassen und durch anschauen was dort
alles gibt
als ich haben uns ja letztendlich für
die dunklere küche entschieden aber
nicht tief schwarz sondern die artis
front das heißt dies einfach je nach
licht etwas dunkler oder auch heller und
wir versuchen jetzt also was ich schon
ganz schön finde dass wir die
küchengeräte also die zwei backöfen gar
nicht ganz normal standardmäßig hin in
der küche integriert haben sondern darum
hat die nische eingebaut da kommen wir
gleich noch rückwand weil ich glaube es
ist einfacher wenn wir jetzt keine
fliesen verlegen oder holz sondern
einfach eine rückwand aufnehmen da kommt
doch immer muss man auch mal überlegen
also auch für euch zuhause falls in der
küche plant ist einfacher wenn ihr alles
bei einem küchenplaner besorgt weil er
dann wirklich auch mit der lieferzeit
mit dem planen mit dem einbauen es geht
einfach alles über eine hand und dann
hat man da auch normalerweise echt kein
problem ist schon mal besser ja
natürlich dürfen minister gray nicht
vergessen also sarah hat eine katze hat
so ein bisschen das problem dass das
katzenfutter überall steht und ich
glaube da kameras ganz gutes integrieren
vielleicht nach vorne am messplatz und
die zwei großen kühlschränke wir können
also ohne probleme mit den 60 zentimeter
breiten schrank tauschen und da irgend
einer art und weise im regal 1
[Musik]
der jagt er ist ja innenarchitekt das
heißt er denkt nicht nur an die küche
sondern an das gesamte wohnkonzept und
deswegen haben sie überlegt dass wir
praktisch aus der küche heraus ins
esszimmer so ein element mitnehmen und
da hast du dieses sideboard mit
integriert und für die echt schön also
das wird da sagen da kann sie dann auch
wein gläser geschirr lagern damit es
auch nicht so weit zum tisch getragen
werden muss ist schon immer schön wenn
man so aus der küche heraus alles mit
einem wohnbereich einnimmt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
naja
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die kirchen pläne sind jetzt endlich da
und die küche wird gerade produziert und
bald angeliefert ich weiß nun wird er
relativ schnell ungeduldig wenn man die
küchen pläne hat und dann weiß ich muss
jetzt ein paar wochen warten bis die
küche da ist aber ihr könnt die zeit
überbrücken indem ihr euch die pläne
nimmt und zum beispiel eure küchen zonen
schon mal definiert und euch überlegt
was räume ich wohin küchen sollen zu
definieren macht auch wirklich sinn denn
man spart ganz viel arbeitszeit in der
küche man spart laufwege und alles ist
top organisiert so dass man nichts mehr
suchen muss und alles wirklich seinen
platz hat und jetzt nehme ich mir
einfach diese pläne zur hand habe mir
schon ein paar aufschrieb über eco sarah
und ihren sohn gemacht und eben auch
schon gedanken darüber gemacht wie ich
die küche dekorieren möchte und das kann
ich jetzt hier alles ganz kurz planen
und mit daneben auch noch überlegen was
muss ich besorgen an werkzeug was
brauche ich vielleicht noch an
dekomaterialien was kann ich noch selber
basteln und wie richtig am ende die
küche ein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe jetzt auch überlegt dass ich
einen schrank für den sohn von eco und
sarah reserviere dass er dort sein
geschirr platzieren kann seine
vorratsdosen festwirt dosen aber auch
zum beispiel werkzeug was er in der
küche mit benutzen kann um mama und papa
zu helfen und unter die arme zu greifen
und da ist wichtig dass kinder einfach
an ihre eigene schublade drankommt so
könnte sie nämlich im arbeitsalltag
einfach mit in die haushaltstätigkeiten
integrieren spülmaschine ausräumen
spülmaschine einräumen er kann den tisch
mithelfen zu decken und eben auch selber
mit backen und kochen und kommt so eben
auch ganz gesund und schön und
spielerisch eben auch an lebensmittel
ran und so kann man kindern eigentlich
echt schon beibringen so ein bisschen
verantwortung auch zu übernehmen und
einfach daheim mitzuhelfen
[Musik]
ich habe ich die küchen sonne kochen und
ich finde es aber ganz praktisch wenn
man vor dem herd steht dass man nicht
die dinge die man braucht direkt
darunter hart weil dort muss man ständig
weg hier was rauskramen sondern wenn
hier der koch platz ist dass hier neben
dran das werkzeug ist was ich für den
platz brauche und hier das werkzeug ist
was ich dafür brauche da muss man
einfach wenn einer davor steht nicht
über die person weg schicken sondern
kann eben kurz an den anderen platz sind
die gläser für den alltag würde ich hier
direkt über dem backofen integrieren
denn ich habe hier von blancco soda und
hott das heißt man kann da gefiltertes
stilles wasser ziehen aber auch
gefiltertes sprudelwasser direkt von der
armatur vom wasserhahn vom spielplatz
sozusagen das ist am praktischen alltag
da kommen auch karaffen hin aber gläser
die ich zum anrichten des tisches
brauche die werde ich dann auf jeden
fall im esszimmer integrieren daten
einen kürzeren weg ich hab mir jetzt
meine gedanken gemacht und wenn es noch
ein paar besorgungen machen müssen ich
werde pflanzen noch aussuchen
küchenkräuter in meinem shop noch dinge
bestellen dann noch um zum baumarkt
fahren müssen wandfarbe kaufen alle
besorgungen machen und dann würde ich
sagen legen wir direkt los mit den de
weiß was ich für die küche jetzt noch
selber herstellen werde ich werde jetzt
hier aus soft ton ein paar deko
gegenstände machen softphone ist
praktischen ton der einfach bei
raumtemperatur trocknet man kann ihn
aber auch brennen das gibt es eigentlich
in jedem bastelgeschäft und zwar könnt
ihr euch eine alte musik box oder auch
ein altes glas nehmen und auch hier face
lions drauf machen und später werde ich
das ganze dann wenn es getrocknet ist
einfach mit farbe besprühen und habe
wirklich schöne vasen diese hier
natürlich nur für trockenblumen außer
man wird jetzt noch ein glas reinsetzen
wer aber natürlich unlogisch und diese
hier wäre sogar für blumen mit wasser
[Musik]
meine was ist angetrocknet ich habe die
teile jetzt nochmal mit sekundenkleber
bisschen angeben müssen der heißkleber
hat nicht ganz so gut gehalten das habe
ich hier ne lackier box und nehme
einfach sprühfarbe und lackiert das
ganze
[Musik]
jetzt mache ich noch individualisierte
untersetzer aus diesem ton rollt ihn
jetzt auf 5 mm stärke aus schlecht an
runde kreise aus und kann dann mit keks
ausstechen die so kleine buchstaben zum
einprägen haben einfach noch den namen
einprägen
[Musik]
die untersetzer lag ich jetzt auch noch
und wird sehr sie dann noch mit goldener
farbe
[Musik]
jetzt mal ich noch ein bild und zwar
habe ich jetzt hier drei leinwände
besorgt die alle gleich groß sind und
das hänge ich dann ins esszimmer
wahrscheinlich über diese anrichte und
da mache ich es einfach ein modernes
bild nehmen dafür auch die wandfarbe die
ich schon gekauft habt die wandfarbe
kommt in die küche das bild kommt ins
esszimmer so kann ich küche und
wohnbereich so ein bisschen miteinander
verbinden und mache jetzt hier einfach
so eine grundierung mit zu drei kreisen
und dann male ich die pflanzen drauf und
ist echt super einfach könnt euch auch
auf interest bisschen inspiration holen
und ich startet direkt damit das bild
auch schnell fertig wird
[Musik]
die bilder sind jetzt getrocknet und die
werde ich noch verschönern mit diesem
blatt metallplättchen so heißen sie das
ist ein gold im etat ist kein echtes
gold und stadtrat ist einfach ein kleber
auf und kommt stellenweise gold drauf
und dann passt es glaube ich ganz gut
[Musik]
fürs thema katzenstation habe ich mir
folgendes überlegt die katze hat drei
mädchen also wasser trockenfutter
nassfutter und ich habe mir gedacht ich
nehme einfach diese drei im ein
schälchen und bauer eine katzen ab
station aus holz und zwar soll das ganze
so aussehen ich habe mir praktisch eine
holzplatte da kommen drei kreise rhein
in die kreise passen natürlich die
recherchen perfekt rechts und links dann
noch zwei stützen und dann habe ich im
prinzip eine halterung
da ich hier keinen kreis schneider habe
brauche ich jetzt professionelle hilfe
und fahre eben mal kurz nochmal streifen
nämlich der eugen eigenes
tischlermeister und ich glaube er hat
die richtigen werkzeuge um mir zu helfen
hat mit
[Musik]
eugen ich weiß wirklich kader nun zum
schneider wäre dann dran aber ich
brauche dringend eine hilfe ich brauchen
katzen apfalter ok und katzen
nachtfalter ich will hier so drei katzen
näpfchen trockenfutter nassfutter wasser
ok und da hätte ich gerne aus holz warte
solange zeichnen dabei das gerne und
ich habe keinen kreis schneider okay
aber ich weiß im leben muss man nicht
alles können man muss nur wissen machen
sich nur zu helfen wissen oder oder die
richtigen leute kennen wir kriegen hier
überschneiden und dann mache ich den
kreis raus ja katzenstation des geräts
zeugen sei dank
ist sie haben hier paar aktuelle ist zum
beispiel
dann haben wir hier noch so birke ich
habe dies zu gelb gern und hier immer
buche okay das
einführte ich finde ich glaube die haben
sogar einen eigenen tisch dann passte
gut
zu bringen
[Musik]
also das passt er perfekt zu mir jetzt
einfach nur noch dran schrauben und
bisschen schleifen können fertig richtig
närrisch die tolle idee wenn man ein
tischler das vertrauen vater der einem
die löcher zu wort so schneidet
[Musik]
ob sie reden chef ich muss nochmal kommt
ja
immer in die massenproduktion
sendeten mit der eigentlichen botschaft
willst du die lehrstelle bei mir
anfangen ja nein vielleicht
ok ich
schreib mal
[Musik]
okay manchmal eine kleine
qualitätskontrolle
aber kann man sich aber noch gaspreisen
kohlezeichnung
[Musik]
ok-chef jetzt jetzt ist es gut also wie
ich finde hat sich unser lehrling sehr
gut angestellt
also auch in die massenproduktion
mir kommen wir uns noch und dann hier
[Musik]
ich finde das ist das schönste foto
apfalter die die welt je gesehen hat
sehr schön danke dir und david geht
setzt direkt weiter
luftschiffs und ihr gebiet so war so
und es aber eine schöne laden ich glaube
da gehe ich rein da finde ich bestimmt
was
hallo
[Musik]
als viertes mal gucken dass ich so
farben mäßig schon richtung schwarz
anthrazit grau bleibe aber vielleicht
bringe ich auch doch ein bisschen das
blaue rein was ich eben an den stühlen
von sarah und eco entdeckt habe und dann
kann ich so ein bisschen mit
farbakzenten in der küche arbeiten ja
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht ob sie gerne humor
grillen aber die pfanne ist ganz cool
die so vielseitig glaube die nämlich auf
jeden fall mit aber wahrscheinlich die
kleinere die passt nämlich auch super in
den backofen und diese kleinen fähnchen
da kann sie entweder können so was darin
anbraten oder sie können auch das ganze
zum servieren benutzen die sind auch
recht schön
ich hab nur die befürchtung dass dieser
wagen nicht ausreicht ja ja
für ecke und sarah werde ich auf jeden
fall porzellangeschirr nehmen und ich
find's ganz schön wenn kinder ihr
eigenes geschirr haben vor allem
geschehe was vielleicht nicht ganz so
schnell zerbrechen kann und deswegen
denke ich nehme ich hier auf jeden fall
im mai geschirr mit so kleine teile aber
jetzt nicht nur einen sondern direkt
vier weil sie mal freunde da hat dann
können sie den tisch gemeinsam decken
und dann auch viel zu kleine tassen und
kleine schälchen
die berlin ich glaube die sind echt
perfekt passend zu ihren stühlen und die
liegen einfach so schön in der hand ich
liebte die tassen von denen nämlich auch
welche mit und bald gibt noch die
kleinen sehr max die für kleine
espressotassen und die hessen sehr mag
weil ich heute den sieg und deswegen
habe ich meine kleine espressotassen
haben sie erwartet man
ja beim besteck kann man schon so ein
bisschen eine typ beschreibung machen
wir haben verschiedene bestecks your
majesty apa klar
bausparer hipster da kann man schon
gucken was zu einem passt ich glaube ja
majesty das zwar schön ich glaube sarah
wird es vielleicht auch gefallen mit
seinem feinen goldrand aber ich gab es
passt doch nicht so ganz klar ist auch
sehr schön
mit dem gold unten aber ich glaube für
den alltag und für eco will ich so beide
sehen vielleicht auch nicht
ich glaube ich bin doch bei upper class
bei den beiden
ja da haben wir nämlich den glänzenden
löffel und hier dieses satte angriff ich
glaube die beiden sind upper class
ich nehme upper class mit oder das passt
doch
aber klar
[Musik]
kochgeschirr
ich glaube dass nämlich einmal so die
ganze palette mit an werkzeugen denn ich
habe eigentlich schon darauf geachtet
dass ich nur wegzug aus man auch
wirklich braucht das heißt einmal von
jedem und da kann ich auch mini werkzeug
mitnehmen für den leiter dann hat er
nämlich auch sein koch gesteckt wobei
ich die miniserie muss ich sagen selber
auch gern nutzt für kleine töpfe
empfangen und gerade mein lieblingsteil
der löffel den immer trägt zwei mal mit
ach kommt dreimal hat jeder seinen
eigenen
und dann können wir damit und ich finde
es einfach gut weil das hat wirklich
einfach so einen schönen edelstahl kern
der für die stabilität sorgt das heißt
man kann auch wirklich schwere stakes
auch wirklich wenden und die silikon
beschichtung ist praktisch getan hat das
dünnste doch nicht aus es stimmt auch
nicht ist alles lebensmittelecht
geruchsneutral geschmacksneutral
hygienisch kann man in der spülmaschine
reinigen und man kann auch wirklich ins
heiße frittierfett damit da passiert gar
nichts und das ist schon gut dass da
kratzt die töpfe und pfannen nicht ist
flexibel gibt es in verschiedenen farben
also ich finde es schon sehr universell
muss ich sagen
[Musik]
ich glaube das meiste habe ich jetzt
sich lade ist das auto voll und dann
geht es weiter noch deko besorgen und
morgen werden wir noch pflanzen besorgen
und dann glaube ich kaufe ich bete ich
habe ich alles und hatte an alles
gedacht
pflanzen machen jeden raum schöner und
wohnlicher deswegen shoppen
wirtspflanzen
[Musik]
doping opfer
ich kann klamotten nicht stoppen aber
deko eine richtung ja ja ja
[Musik]
wir sagen das reicht um das haus von
familie borer wohnlich zu machen
zumindest in der küche und dem westen
war
ich liebe pflanzen
[Musik]
murat murat
murat cicek
dann können wir gehen ja okay ich hoffe
wir haben nichts vergessen wir fahren
jetzt mit unserem team auto mit unserem
elektrobus haben jetzt schön aufgetankt
laden jetzt alles ein aber wir haben so
viel gepäck das wird sondern transporter
gemietet haben weil es ist wirklich
extrem viel wir fahren jetzt zurück nach
köln hoch kriegen jetzt hier alles rein
und dann sehen wir uns gleich in köln
ok count wir können einladen
müssen gucken dass katzen kind sich
nicht mit ins auto schmuggeln
[Musik]
also was geht
hallo zu sagen
hey
ich jetzt echt voll viel getan haben
gestern geben
düsseldorf glich wahlkampf sieht schon
richtig wohnlich aus
wie ist die stimmung seid ihr so
einzugsbereit oder ja wir sind sogar
schon drüber irgendwie wir wollen
unbedingt rein und jetzt müssen sie die
letzten kleinigkeiten noch gemacht und
wenn die küche steht kommt ihr dann
direkt rein oder dann gehen wir rein
wir müssen zahlt jetzt echt so mache ich
meine erwartet wahrscheinlich die
letzten tage wochen monate immer hier
auf der baustelle
jetzt wird euch dann jetzt von ihr
verabschieden
titel entgegen nehmen und dann sagen
sehen wir uns in fünf tagen wieder habt
ihr einen
tapeziertisch
hier bestimmt unten was meinst du oder
beim augenmaß
die machen wir dann mit der
mitbestimmung wasser wagen
was vielleicht ist ja noch flower power
[Musik]
wir haben schon gescherzt dass die sache
sich bestimmt irgendwo versteckt mit
sultan kleidung
und im fernrohr höher weil sie es nicht
aushalten kann aber ich werde dir schön
ablenken okay ich bin gespannt
[Musik]
falls nicht dann gibt es wahrscheinlich
bald das haus zu verkaufen
natürlich gefällt
das wird schön wie was machen wir jetzt
beginnt die frau gehört
ein schild einfach
ok aber was ist wenn es wirklich
komplett pink wird das wird schon kommen
so wirklich alle wände
ich habe jetzt die schlüssel sie kommen
da rein wir werden jetzt noch unser auto
aus laden dann geht es los morgen früh
kommen schon die möbel die küchenmöbel
von nobilia geliefert und ja da geht es
mit der kirche los ich bin gespannt
entschuldigung ich sorgt hier für
unterhaltung und für für das leibliche
wohl
ich hab hier streuselkuchen dabei ich
meine wenn da nicht plötzlich macht dann
weiß ja auch etwas glücklich machen
[Musik]
gut die hälfe mit was kann ich tun
[Applaus]
die aufbauzeit überbrücke ich jetzt mit
dem eintopfen meiner pflanzen und zwar
kommt jetzt erst mal eine schicht blade
hohenrain dann eine tolle erde für die
pflanzen dann die pflanze oder obendrauf
nummer platoon
war einfach schon mal eine schöne
drainage das wasser kann ein bisschen
abfließen wenn man vielleicht doch aus
versehen zu viel gegossen wurde und es
gibt eben keine staunässe in den
pflanzen
am besten direkt eine erde nehmen die
auch schon tolle nährstoffe hat dann
muss man die ersten drei monate auch gar
nicht düngen
[Musik]
ich habe mich jetzt davon geschlichen
während die männer jetzt nämlich noch
ausbauen werde ich schon mal mit sarah
die alte küche entrümpeln und einfach
alles mitnehmen was mit soll und den
rest kann sehr verschenken
jetzt geht's an den umzug und thema
umzug bedeutet natürlich immer dass man
wenn man möchte alte dinge mitnimmt oder
sich eben neue dinge holt und im besten
fall macht dies wirklich so dass ihr
beim umzug schon überlegt was möchte ich
mitnehmen und was ich da was brauche ich
wirklich nicht denn die meisten machen
schon den großen fehler und schleppen
erstmal alles mit weil so ein hausbau
und umzug ist schon immer auch relativ
stressig man packt an alles einfach in
kisten also wenn ihr euch die zeit
nehmen könnt so wie wir jetzt dann
müsste doch direkt aus und nimmt nur das
mit ins haus was mit soll dann spart ihr
euch wirklich dieses große kisten
schleppen und hat vor allem keinen müll
im haus den ihr da eben nicht haben
wollte also ihr leben dann gucken wir
doch jetzt in ihrer küche ihr sagt
einfach aus ihr mitnehmen wollte
vielleicht auch erinnerungsstücke
emotionale dinge geschenke und die
sachen wo er sagt das möchte ich gar
nicht im neuen haus das lassen einfach
da könnte wahrscheinlich weiter
verschenken oder spenden oder es gibt
bestimmt jemanden der es dann noch
gebrauchen kann also los geht's ok also
ich hab hier einmal die rocker tassen
also das service das habe ich von meiner
schwiegermutter bekommt das mit vorsicht
das muss auf jeden fall mit
und ganz richtig super mario und puppet
welcher von der live
[Musik]
ich liebe ja tees und die müssen mit
daten ja ich nehme ich auch gerne ins
müsli ja ich glaube das passt zu dir das
kann eigentlich hier bleiben egger
denkmal nach von dir noch irgendwie war
also ich kann ja auf alles verzichten
aber nicht auf meine konflikt
wenn ich zu hause bin ich kann jetzt
nicht jetzt kann ich nicht
vorrücken ja das ist nämlich auch noch
mit ich habe auch gehofft dass noch so
was ich haben uns fern ist
also viel ist es ja nicht im prinzip
haben wir jetzt wirklich nur so ein paar
erinnerungsstücke und ein paar sachen
von reiter auch lebensmittel das heißt
alles andere kommt bei dazu wir machen
alles neu neuenhaus null anfangen und
jetzt packe ich alles ein paar ins haus
und dann wird eingerichtet
[Musik]
dann können wir helfen gerne ich
rangiere war sehr gut dann bringen wir
das jetzt mal zum auto und dann gehe ich
wieder zurück zu den männern weiter
aufbauen
vorsicht schuhe
[Musik]
jetzt kommen endlich die innenteile nein
[Applaus]
ich mache jetzt schon mal notizen was
ich gleich wofür räumen möchte dann kann
mir mein team nämlich auch gleich helfen
beim einräumen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir sind immer noch beim aufbau und beim
einräumen und bei allen und ich stress
mal die wände dass dies zumindest schon
mal trocken sind wir morgen dann muss
ich ganz fix einräumen dass der konsum
überraschen können
und ich finde gerade bei so einer
dunklen küche ich hatte mir schon
starken kontrast zwischen dunkle und
weiß finde ich persönlich immer nicht
ganz so schön deswegen versuche ich
immer eine warme farbe mit reinzubringen
das macht einfach bisschen gemütlicher
[Musik]
[Applaus]
191 5 bis unterkante und die linien
nämlich jetzt und mal da mit der farbe
weiter
[Musik]
immer ein paar millimeter über der linie
an setzte dann ist das stift nämlich
auch weg immer schön überstreichen um
diese linie schön gerade zu machen könnt
jetzt entweder wandfarbe nehme also die
weiße wandfarbe die darunter ist und so
ein bisschen hier an der kante vom
klebeband streichen oder nehmt einfach
da ist der vorteil man kann direkt
weiter arbeiten kann es überstreichen
einfach so ein bisschen von der pistole
auf den finger in so ein bisschen
abdichten und da mal eine schöne saubere
kante
zum maler track habe ich meine
ausbildung gelernt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die männer sind jetzt hier noch beim
aufbau bis es zeit sparen jede minute
jede stunde zählt jetzt fangen wir schon
mal hier an zu putzen und
ihr herz schon im chaos
[Musik]
ja ich putze grad
und macht dich glücklich
total
ich bin richtig
entspannt
also mich macht putzen glücklich ich
weiß nicht was sarah hat es schwer
[Musik]
haben jetzt hier schon in turbo
geschwindigkeit aufgeräumt jetzt wird
erst mal geputzt das sollte man auch
direkt machen wenn die küche fertig ist
was auch ganz wichtig ist gerade wenn
eben hier viel gebohrt wird und es ist
staubig wirklich erstmal die küche
reinigen und dann an den küchenfronten
erst die folie abziehen wenn es kann
sonst passieren dass einfach der ganze
staub wieder an eurer küche landet und
dann müsste das ganze von vorne machen
also erstmal die üblichen heiligen boden
reinigen wir putzen fenster und alles
mögliche damit wirklich das haus erst
mal staubfrei ist und dann ist der
moment in
dem murat das fenster putzt und ich dann
die folien ab
[Musik]
mario claudio es geschafft oder ihr habt
geschafft
seid ihr happy mit der kirche schon
zuzufügen
jetzt wissen nichts davon aber ihr seid
doch schon unsere zwei lieblingsmotive
bei nobilia
wir verlosen mit mobiliar zusammen und
mit unseren partnern zusammen bosch
kesseböhmer blanco verlosen wir eine
community küche das heißt ganz
deutschland darf sich dann bewerben und
mitmachen und dann werden wir 43 und
alle anderen gemeinsam eine küche planen
organisieren und einbauen und dann an
jemanden von der community vergeben
freut ihr euch schon drauf eine hobby so
ein schönes großes projekt zu sagen ja
sehr schön das heißt ihr seid jetzt hier
mit der küche fertig wir dürfen
übernehmen einrichten einräumen
dekorieren müssen wir etwas beachten
macht geputscht ist jetzt können wir die
folie abziehen das ist übrigens der sz
ist ein moment der schönste moment in
der küche die folien abzuziehen denn
dann ist sie fertig ja das machen wir
jetzt noch zusammen so als kleines
zwischen highlight
[Musik]
gott
morgen
guten morgen
heute treffen uns hier um einzukaufen
wir müssen nämlich grundnahrungsmittel
besorgen und die küche ausstatten das
heißt wir gehen aber mit euch zusammen
durch und schauen was man gerne esse ich
meine ich weiß ja schon bolls smoothies
gesundes ich würde euch einfach mal
zeigen was man so als
grundnahrungsmittel zu hause haben
sollte was man auf vorrat kaufen kann
wie man lebensmittel lagern kann und was
man noch als frisches dazu holt so dass
man jederzeit gesund und lecker essen
kann da habe ich alles was ich will
alles
ich habe nur die befürchtung ein wagen
reicht nicht
[Musik]
hör mal weißt du was ich am meisten
braucht dafür mein leben ist natürlich
eine extra
noch mal nämlich schmerzen waren so
viele wie
[Musik]
ja frisches obst und gemüse ist
natürlich immer sehr wichtig dass man
das zuhause hat aber mein tipp ist auch
immer konserven oder auch tiefkühlwaren
gerade bei tiefkühl bari ist nämlich so
dass die wirklich direkt nach der ernte
schockgefrostet wird und dann immer was
vitaminreiches gesundes nährstoffreiches
zu hause aber auch dosenware ist immer
ganz gut vor allem wenn man vielleicht
noch mal nicht zum einkaufen kommt hat
man trotzdem was zu hause was man eben
schnell mal zubereiten kann während die
zwei hier also an der frischetheke sind
bei obst und gemüse werde ich hier noch
ein paar lebensmittel einkaufen
ja so auf den weg gebracht zu treffen
mit dem regal wenn ich berate dann
stimmt seit dem lidl sportics da stand
ich in jedem regal referate
ohne sie über die anderen automaten die
sind frisch auf
die sind die kleinen sind aromatische
[Musik]
hallo
haben wir genug meinen extrakt
ihr könnt jetzt übrigens schon weit im
kassiervorgang alles so ein bisschen
vorsortieren dann habt ihr später beim
einpacken einfacher und leichter ja das
machen wir jetzt mal eben schnell und
dann geht's zurück in die küche ich doch
sarah das war ja wohl auch das ist
zugleich ein wenig weiter mischt euch
ein bisschen gedulden warum ist ihr
problem aber dachte ich ja wir sind bald
fertig und dann könnt ihr rein und dann
wirklich direkt los
[Musik]
unser transporter morath haben es noch
vor apple hat sich über netflix arme
gesehen mit wie zucchini und karotten wo
sind die chips die energie war alles ja
ein paar sünden sind dabei so ein
pudding mal aber was ist ein
polizist gesellschaft dass die chips
also was er sich nicht mehr wirklich
nicht mehr gesund ist sofern ich werde
ja nicht jünger mir gerade vor wie so
werdet ihr stimmt alles nicht irgendwo
haben sie zeit irgendwo
[Musik]
hersteller richtig so
hier haben die
schokolade 80 prozent
ach da seid ihr ja schon wieder ich habe
auch in dieser woche beziehungsweise bei
dieser folge
der
zu tief
achter seid ihr ja sehr schön ich habe
auch dieses mal wieder einem 1000 euro
gutschein für meinen shop zu gewinnen
und ich habe mir überlegt welche frage
stellen könnte ich bin ja schon so ein
bisschen mit der musik von eco
aufgewachsen also eko fresh war einer
der ersten rapper die ich kannte hat
mich begleitet von meiner kindheit bis
jetzt ins erwachsenenalter ihr könnt ihr
gerne mal in die kommentare schreiben
mit welcher musik ihr aufgewachsen sei
und dann nehmt ihr automatisch an der
verlosung teil und mit etwas glück
gehört 1000 euro kutschern bald dir und
wenn wir jetzt grad schon bei der
unterbrechung sind es gibt ja auch noch
eine weitere neuigkeit nämlich die
community küche für pimp my kitchen die
bewerbungsphase läuft ab dem nächsten
jahr ab anfang des jahres und da schau
dir gerne einfach bei pimp my kitchen de
vorbei da gibt es nämlich alle infos ja
und wo wird es über eine unterbrechung
sind würde ich sagen man doch gleich ein
bisschen werbung
[Musik]
von sarah mögen ja guten kaffee deswegen
wird das hilft die kaffee und müsli ecke
denn das frühstück ist ihnen auch sehr
wichtig und sie trinken ja auch ganz
gerne kaffee bei ihren freunden die den
kaffee sogar selber rüsten und auch nach
belieben malen und deswegen bekommen
jetzt weil ich hier einfach eine griff
kaffeemaschine das sind sie träger die
die kaffeemühle und noch mit dabei und
eco hat auch schon gesagt er möchte ich
da ein bisschen reinlesen und rein
arbeiten und dann eben auch sein café
selber machen deswegen wird das ganze
jetzt schön dekoriert ich werde dir auf
jeden fall auch seine cornflakes mit
platzieren die haferflocken dass sie die
immer schön griffbereit haben ein pakt
affen und der rest wird praktisch
darüber und darunter sortiert so dass
man alles hier griffbereit hat was man
eben für einen kaffee oder auch fürs
gute gesunde müsli frühstück brauchen
kann
ich habe ich jetzt noch ein schönes
tablett besorgt das wird so das café
tablett da kommt zum beispiel auch
zucker drauf und alles was man eben
braucht und dann kann man dieses tablett
auch mal mit zum esstisch nehmen wenn
man gäste hat oder eben hier in der ecke
dekorativ stehen lassen
[Musik]
so gefällt mir die kaffee und misty war
richtig gut versteckt habe ich jetzt
hier schon drin hier das café zubehör
für die griff kaffeemaschine hier noch
ein paar bowles fürs müsli kassen
reserve tassen alles hier drinnen und
weil jetzt hier auch so die frühstücks
station ist werde ich hier unten einfach
noch den toaster mit rein nehmen denn
ich glaube ich was heißt ich glaube ich
weiß ja dass der eco fan von zucker und
ei ist aber vielleicht mag auch ab und
zu und sucht trost wenn er nicht gerade
immer low carb ist deswegen kommt hier
ein osterei der auch als multifunktions
grill dient und den kann ich jetzt hier
schon verstorben
[Musik]
normalerweise habe ich immer diese
kräutertöpfe von gvo sich unten
praktisch die pflanze des wasser ziehen
kann aber ich habe hier auch dieses
regal system mit den pflanzen lichtern
das ist unser wachstums liegt das
speziell für die pflanzen eingestellt
damit sie im auto wachsen können und
hier habe ich eben auch diese körbe
zum einpflanzen schon direkt mit dabei
und da setzt sich jetzt die pflanzen mit
erde rein und dann können sarah und eco
die pflanzen schön gießen
[Musik]
doch die kenwood cooking chef gummi
damit sarah und eco auch schön kochen
können und hier habe ich jetzt ein ganz
besonderes zubehör dazu gewählt nämlich
den entsafter ich weiß nämlich dass
beide sich sehr gesunder lernen
smoothies auch lieben deswegen haben wir
da hinten dance music maker aber ich
wollte auch noch einen entsafter wein
saft dann noch mal was anderes ist und
ich habe hier drüben auch schon das
zubehör gerichtet und zeigt euch mal ein
richtig cool trick wie ihr das zubehör
cool verstauen können komm mit
ich hab jetzt eine große geräumige
schublade und diesellok platte und die
passt hier perfekt rein und ich habe
kleine stäbe so wie da drüben im schrank
auch und haben noch die elemente und wo
ist hier die löcher die sowieso schon da
sind einfach ein bisschen tiefer
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich hier schon den
kühlschrank einräumen ich habe hier
einmal einen richtig großen kühlschrank
und auf der anderen seite
einen gefrierschrank und es sieht aus
wie ein mega xxl seit by side und jetzt
kann ich hier den kühlschrank verein
räumen im gefrierfach da werde ich jetzt
einfach nicht rein stellen können sarah
und eco einfach selbst machen
und jetzt kann ich hier alles recht
stellen dann ist es auch schon mal
bereit
[Musik]
kommen wir jetzt zu meinem lieblings
schrank und zwar ist es dieser hier der
kesseböhmer tandem tandem deswegen weil
man hier vorne praktisch ein drittel
seines vorrats hat und zwei drittel des
vorrats schiebt sich nach vorne sobald
der schrank geöffnet wird ich habe einen
tollen überblick habe die zutaten immer
schön griffbereit aber dieser schrank
verstaubt nicht nur zutaten und
lebensmittel ihr könnt hier auch
geschirr verstauen und wirklich ganz
toll auch kaffeetassen hier teller
geschehe alles mögliche darin lagern und
auch wirklich ordentliches gewicht und
ich habe jetzt hier alle zutaten mal
hergerichtet alle lebensmittel und ich
schaue einfach was hier so alles
reingeht und wie ich hier alles
sortieren und dann habe ich hier meine
vorratsbehälter ich denke unsere haben
nicht so viele geöffnete vorräte wie ich
daher werde ich jetzt auch
wahrscheinlich ein paar vorratsbehälter
wieder rausnehmen dafür zutaten
reinstellen und was ich hier ganz schön
finde und deswegen zeige ich euch das
auch mal der schrank ist einfach
komplett individuell einstellbar das
heißt ich kann hier die tabla die ich
hier habe einfach raus hängen wieder
weiter tiefer hängen komplett wegnehmen
oder noch zusätzliche einfach dazu
hängen das sieht man hier ganz gut die
hänge hinten an so haken dran kann ich
ganz einfach rausnehmen woandershin
hängen oder auch mal tiefer oder höher
als ihr seht hier ich hab schon
ordentlich viele zutaten das waren
richtig volle einkaufskorb und ihr
werdet staunen aber der schrank ist ein
richtiges raumwunder da wird alles
reinpassen
ok ich starte
[Musik]
sid 1 so jetzt ganz gut aus muss ich
sagen da oben jetzt noch vielleicht
snacks
habe ich hier von eco das von sarah und
dann kann man ja dafür leider auch
irgendwie massenexodus luces reinpacken
hier guck mal hier vorratsschrank
ganze einkaufen ich glaube das sind ganz
allein bleiben ein großes anliegen
einkaufswagen voll fahren sind ja die
ganze verkaufswagen ganz schön wieder
hier rein karmann war sehr lecker aber
täglich aus
ach komm komm doch mal rein
die doch perfekt auf
ich bin auch
die farbe passt ganz 38
wir sind aachen sind
die
[Musik]
ja
schön ja jetzt jetzt ist er perfekt zu
machen
jetzt eine kleine pause und dann geht's
weiter
es ist vollbracht eko fresh küche ist
fertig und jetzt gibt es eine küchen
tour
[Musik]
die moderne mobile küche hat eine sata
matte oberfläche ist anthrazit grau und
hat auch eine schöne matte arbeitsplatte
die so ein bisschen in lederoptik hat
die küche ist sehr modern gestaltet ist
sehr großräumig aber ist natürlich auch
trotzdem sehr warm da ich ganz viele
lichtelemente mit eingearbeitet habe
viele pflanzen eine kaffeebar eine
küchen insel eine smoothie ecke eine
richtig coole dunstabzugshaube die
einfach auch so ein highlight in der
küche darstellt ich habe überall ganz
viele schubkästen verbaut viel stauraum
sichtbaren stauraum aber auch
unsichtbaren stauraum wer hier auch bald
ein set ist sarahs katze mister gray und
mister gray hat hier auch einen
stellenwert und einen platz in der küche
nehme ich hier schön aufgeräumt haben
wir hier die futterstation und direkt
darüber unsichtbar verstaut einfach
stauraum für das katzenfutter kann man
schön verschließen und während den
futter zeiten einfach hier geöffnet
lassen mister gray kann hier rein kann
sich an dem katzenfutter und am wasser
bedienen und verschmilzt einfach schön
mit der küche und vielleicht ist bei
euch zu hause auch so bei uns zumindest
ja wenn man in der küche steht ist es
oft so dass man briefe und unterlagen
und einfach schreibkram irgendwo mal in
der schublade verschwinden lässt aber
wenn ihr direkt die schublade gehabt wo
es verstehen könnt sie in der küche
gleich viel organisierter und
aufgeräumter aus das heißt hier hat
jetzt alles seinen platz was man so im
täglichen gebrauch eben hat mehr zeug
pflaster tesa stifter kugelschreiber und
so weiter ich verstehe wie übrigens auch
die fernbedienungen und die brauche ich
zum beispiel auch wie hier für meine
pflanzen wand das ist ein regalsystem
von nobilia sieht richtig moderne aus
hat eine schöne beleuchtung aber die
beleuchtung hat auch noch in sicht man
kann nämlich auch noch pflanzen
beleuchtung wählen so dass pflanzen
einfach schön wachsen können und
praktischen wachstums licht haben und
des wachstums liegt das sieht nicht nur
toll aus und sorgt wirklich auch dafür
dass die pflanzen und kräuter hier schön
wachsen da kann man sich hier in der
küche immer ganz frisch bedienen kann
das regal aber auch nutzen zur
dekoration zur aufbewahrung und ich
finde es bringt einfach so eine schöne
wohnliche atmosphäre in die küche mit
rein
die backöfen habe ich hier an der seite
platziert ist echt ein schöner platz vor
allem sind sie schön auf ökonomischer
höhe man muss sich nicht nach unten
drückten hat alles schön im blick und
ich finde sie sehr noch echt toll aus
sind beides backöfen von bosch beides
carbon black geräte und die sind auch
beide wirklich komplett voll
ausgestattet martin praktisch die
funktionen dass man ganz individuell
backzeit back temperaturen bereits art
einstellen kann aber man kann auch wenn
man vielleicht noch nicht so gut backen
und kochen kann einfach die es ist
funktion nutzen und sich komplett leiten
lassen das heißt ich kann zum beispiel
ein fleischgericht zubereiten kann im
braten thermometer verwenden hier oben
meine fleisch art eben einstellen
temperatur garzeit stellt sich alles von
alleine ein und ich hab dann wirklich
ganz einfach ein perfektes ergebnis
genauso kann ich auch im bug assistenten
verwenden buck assistent bedeutet ich
muss auch gar nicht darauf achten wann
der kuchen ist denn das macht der
backofen für mich der misst nämlich die
feuchtigkeit und den sauerstoff im
backofen und schaltet dann den backofen
aus wenn der gar punkt perfekt erreicht
ist das heißt der kuchen ist immer
perfekt da es nicht so durch und wird
nicht trocken und kommt immer gleich
perfekt aus dem ofen heraus
und direkt darunter habe ich auch noch
stauraum für backformen und zubehörteile
wie es hier für die küchenmaschine zum
beispiel und darüber habe ich auch noch
platz in diesen glasvitrinen für
backformen gläser geschirr und so weiter
und hier sind wir schon direkt am wasser
platz und ich mag es immer ganz gerne
wenn ich vor der spüle stehe und etwas
abwarten möchte dass ich rechts dann zum
beispiel den geschirrspüler habt der hat
übrigens open airs ist das und
eingebauter geschirrspüler von bosch und
der open es ist da kann ich einfach mit
der hand dran dann geht die tür von
alleine auf und der oasis ist auch
gleichzeitig der fisch & ride denn wenn
der geschirrspüler fertig gespült und
getrocknet hat öffnet sich die tür
automatisch die restfeuchtigkeit geht
raus um das geschirr ist wirklich 100%
trocken dann habe ich jetzt hier wie
gesagt die spüle ist eine richtig große
geräumige blanco spüle und es ist alles
in schwarz gehalten sehr edel & noble
und hier passt auch wirklich mal ein
richtig großer topf rein es passt auch
mal was vom grill rein und backblech und
alles was ihr euch vorstellen könnt denn
das spülbecken hat wirklich eine ganz
ganz große breite und man kann hier auch
mal was drin abstellen und hat hier auch
diese zwei ebenen das heißt ich habe
hier diese zwei abstellflächen die
individuell reinlegen kann und eben auch
mal einen topf drauf stellen kann und
mal wasser einlaufen lassen kann oder
auch beim spülen beim abgießen und so
weiter verwenden kann ich habe hier das
blanco hat und so das system das
bedeutet ich muss nie wieder kisten
schleppen denn ich hab hier wasser
gefüllter sprudelwasser eiskalt so wie
ich das haare möchte hier habe ich die
blancos oder station ich hab hier zum
einen ganz normales leitungswasser warm
und kalt
zum spülen und herz und drehrad damit
kann ich die menge einstellen das wars
aus von 100 bis 1000 milliliter das hat
echt ne schöne haptik und hier oben habe
ich dann noch stille medium und
sprudelwasser und kann da eben
einstellen was ich trinken möchte und
das wasser kommt wirklich eiskalt aus
dem wasser heraus es ist gefiltert und
ich habe einfach den vorteil ich muss
wirklich nie wieder kisten schleppen
oder flaschen kaufen habe ich einfach
meine karaffen und kann es glas direkt
darunter stellen und fertig und hier auf
der linken seite ist da noch der charts
das heißt hier kommt kochend heißes
wasser raus innerhalb von nur wenigen
sekunden
und auch hier habe ich dieses trat kann
die menge einstellen von 100 milliliter
bis 3000 milliliter und betätige diesen
hort einfach indem ich das drehrad
rheinbrücke nach hinten drehe dann sieht
man auch direkt dass es rot aufleuchtet
und dann kann ich mit dem gefäß darunter
gehen drücken und wirklich heißes wasser
zapfen ich kann tee aufgießen ich kann
gemüsebranche ihren ich kann aber auch
mal dinge desinfizieren und wirklich das
heiße wasser sofort weiter verwenden
spar arbeit und eben auch viel zeit und
darunter habe ich das mit
organisationssystem einfach schön hier
unten aufgeteilt noch stauraum für
handtücher für spielgeräte für
spülbürste und natürlich müllbeutel und
ihr direkt am eingang ist die smoothie
bar und mobilitec er mit frischem obst
einem standmixer den gläsern und alles
was man noch so dafür braucht
rezeptbücher hier kann man wirklich
direkt morgens mittags abends waren
immer man lust auf smoothies oder auch
säfte hat einfach sich in saft machen
hier oben habe ich denen kesseböhmer
turn motion eingebaut sind so nicht
viele töpfe aber es können ja noch
einige dazu kommen und hier hat man
einfach den vorteil ich habe zwei jahre
also zwei ebenen und kann die hier
drehen das heißt auch wenn ich da hinten
einfach viel zubehör habt kann ich durch
eine drehbewegung des zubehör nach vorne
holen und muss eben nicht in die
schränke rein griechen bis nach hinten
und eben schauen wo ich alles verstauen
und damit auch wirklich jeder platz
ausgesetzt ist auch hier in der
kleinsten ecke gibt es hier noch einen
15 uhr schrank und der sind einfach so
ein bisschen als zusätzlicher stauraum
ab dieser seite denke hier habe ich ganz
viel stauraum und zwar hier zwei
apotheker schränke die sind wirklich
sehr geräumig und ich mag sie auch sehr
gerne weil sie von beiden seiten
zugänglich sind sind apotheke schränke
vom kesseböhmer mit schönen glas bieten
hier dass man auch schön durchschauen
kann und diese schränke oder diesen
einen habe ich jetzt auch noch gar nicht
gefüllt weil einfach so viel spaß auch
in der küche ist das wird dir dann auch
mit der zeit voll jetzt habe ich erstmal
die ganzen putzmittel hier nach oben
verstört weil einfach hier im haushalt
auch ein kind mit lebt und das kind eben
nicht direkt an die putzmittel kommen
soll hier in der mitte ist auch ganz
schön sieht aus wie ein riesengroßer
side-by-side kühlschrank aber in
wirklichkeit sind zwei geräte nämlich
einbauschrank und einen bleistift den
schrank hier rechts ein großer
gefrierschrank von oben bis unten welt
bald gefüllt wird und links ein großer
geräumt der kühlschrank der einfach hier
unten ein schönes großes wieder fresh
fach hat eine riesige tür und wirklich
ganz viel stauraum für frische
lebensmittel die da einfach perfekt
gekühlt werden können man hat 'ne schöne
ordnung und wirklich stauraum für eine
richtig große familie
und dann habe ich hier ein highlight in
der küche und das tier die kaffee und
müsli ecke die wirklich einmal dekorativ
aber auch sehr funktional und praktisch
ist ich habe hier zum einen begriff
siebträgermaschine das eine richtig
tolle kaffeemaschine mit der man einfach
wirklich wie ein richtig professioneller
wachs truck kaffee machen kann daneben
die kaffeemühle und ecke und sarah
wollten auch eine tolle kaffeemaschine
haben ich habe sie dann auch gefragt er
vollautomat oder doch siebträger und sie
haben beide gesagt sie würden sich schon
mit einer siebträger gerne mal
anfreunden auch so ein bisschen
kaffeebohnen testen verschiedene
richtungen testen und einfach sich so
ein bisschen ein arbeiten und ich denke
deswegen ist es hier echt ein ganz ganz
tolles schmuckstück und hier oben habe
ich noch eine tablet halterung ruhig
template schön ablegen kann gehört auch
zum kesseböhmer mosaik system und hat
hier unten einfach noch schön versteckt
zwei steckdosen was ich hier an der
anrichte auch richtig schön fand ist die
glasfront hier hinten ist eine glasfront
von nobilia die man sich da individuell
dazu gestalten kann und dies hat richtig
schön hat auch eine ganz tolle haptik
ist so ein bisschen matt und hat wie
sein abstieg muster und hier drunter
einfach wieder schöne schubladen mit
besteck hier zum einen aber auch
weiteren bowles und schüsseln tassen und
hier unten weil es eben so eine
frühstücks ecke ist eben auch noch einen
de'longhi grill der eben zum einen
toaster ist aber auch ein grill für die
fisch fleisch und gemüse
in den schubladen habe ich dann noch
kaffee zubehör wie zum beispiel
verschiedene kaffeebohnen ich habe hier
auch tee und die ganzen barista aufsätze
und hier unten noch durch das mobiliar
steckt system einfach platz geschaffen
und ordnung geschaffen für handrührgerät
für stabmixer und für weitere geräte die
man sonst immer in schubladen hat dann
ganz schnell mal durcheinander sind
hinter dieser wunderschönen front
verbirgt sich ein kompletter so vom
markt das verspreche ich euch ich habe
nämlich hier den käse will matt an dem
schrank verbaut und der hat einfach so
viel stauraum aber wirklich übersicht
den sturm hat hier einfach den vorteil
dass alles schön geordnet ist der inhalt
kommt nach vorne und man hat eben alles
im blick
und dann bin ich wieder hier vorne an
der küchen insel und was ich hier noch
integriert habe sind auch noch
steckdosen auf der küchen insel denn
steckdosen das ist so das ding was man
irgendwie am wenigsten beachtet vor
allem am anfang der planung und
irgendwann steht man da und denkt sich
oh gott oh gott brauche ich das jetzt
überall steckdosen und schreibe ich
jetzt so gemacht dass ich mir bis zum
schluss einfach offen gelassen habe wo
ich sie integrieren möchte weil es eben
auch eine arbeitsplatte ist bei der es
eben auch im nachgang noch geht ich habe
ich jetzt zwei steckdosen auf der insel
sind beide mit induktiver ladestationen
für handys ich kann hier einfach denn
die ablegen und kann es einfach hier
laden lassen ganz ohne ladekabel aber
ich kann sie auch aufschieben und habe
direkt eine steckdose oder auch ein
usb-anschluss wenn ich eben mit kabel
laden möchte oder wenn ich ihren start
mix oder ein anderes küchengerät eben
auch mal bedienen möchte
das handy lässt jetzt hier grad liegen
und das ist kurz weiter laden sie habe
ich ein richtig schönes großes kochfeld
von bosch und neunziger und da passen
wirklich auch ganz viele große töpfe
drauf also ich habe hier wirklich drei
stellen und kann auch wirklich die ganz
großen bräter und töpfe drauf stellen es
steht nichts im weg man kann alle
hausgeräte von bosch mit der home
connect verbinden alle die wlan fähig
sind und kann so den vorteil dass man
die geräte miteinander verknüpfen kann
wie zum beispiel kochfeld und münster
zog da hängt jetzt hier an der decke und
der fährt sich dann von ganz alleine
automatisch herunter wenn ich hier was
koche der riecht sozusagen den dunst und
stellt dann individuell eben auch die
stärke 1 ich zeige euch das jetzt einmal
hier weil ich gerade nicht koche mit der
fernbedienung ich kann es nämlich auch
manuell einstellen einmal einschalten
und dann kann ich denn tun sagt so bis
zur beliebigen höhe einfach runterfahren
lassen und natürlich auch nicht
einschalten
und ich finde es macht schon was her als
es echt so highlight auch in der küche
und ich glaube jeder der diesen
dunstabzug sieht fängt an zu stottern
heute koche ich nicht dann ist es ja
oftmals so dass man direkt am herbst
steht und braucht dann koch werkzeug und
viele machen den fehler das ist dann
direkt darunter lagern der mann steht
gerade da und dann kommt vielleicht
jemand brauchen kochlöffel oder
irgendwie doch ein besteck und da muss
man hier immer wegtreten schublade auf
und kann dann erst wieder hin und
deswegen finde ich es ganz praktisch
wenn man es so macht jesus kochfeld und
hier lager ich alles was fürs kochen
benötigt wird und hier ist meine
vorbereitungs zone und hier lager ich
dann alles was eben zur vorbereiten
benötigt wird deswegen zeigen sich jetzt
erst mal das ganze werkzeug für die
vorbereitungs zone die hier links ist
ich hab hier diese innen auszüge und die
einteiler auch von nobilia und habe mir
einfach alles verstaut wie eis
portionierer ich habe hier die flaschen
und dosenöffner ein paar fernbedienungen
oder auf küchenmöbel messer und eben
pizza rädchen
hier drunter ist auch noch weiteres
vorbereitungs werkzeug so was wie
verschiedene schneidegeräte thomas
schneider hier auch den rapido das eben
auch der leiter schön mitmachen kann
messbecher oder auch abdeckungen die man
eben für rührschüssel braucht und große
gegenstände habe ich hier unten verstaut
und ihr seht auch immer wenn ich die
schubladen öffnen habe ich direkten
licht in jeder schublade das einfach die
nobilia beleuchtung ist wirklich in
jeder schublade integriert so dass ich
einfach einen überblick habe und die
schubladen eben nicht so dunkle sind und
man alles schön sieht und ich finds halt
auch echt mega stylus
hier hab ich jetzt die vorbereitungs
zone eine richtig schöne große zone und
hier habe ich jetzt die kennwort cooking
chef integriert weil es einfach ein
gerät ist was super zur küche passt zum
einen optisch aber auch funktional denn
die kennwort cooking chef ist einfach
eine küchenmaschine die alles kann die
erhitzt bis 180 grad sieg anrühren
schlagen mixen kurieren ich habe hier
oben unter vorne einfach noch die
vorteile dass ich da noch super herr
teile anschließen kann wie zum beispiel
oben mixer oder hier vorne den slot
schuster also den entsafter den ich auch
mitgebracht habe und es ist einfach ein
gerät was wirklich mit küche muss ich
sagen schon aufs nächste level bringt
weil es wirklich sehr funktional ist und
ich denke dass sarah öko da auch viel
damit arbeiten werden und hier habe ich
jetzt die schubkästen für das koch
werkzeug was ich eben hier am kochfeld
benötige ich habe hier einfach das
silikon durch steckt was ich echt gut
finde weil es den edelstahl kern hat und
eben sehr sehr stabil ist aber die
silikon beschichtung die einfach nicht
schmelz die temperatur beständig ist bis
350 grad die nicht riecht und einfach
hygienischen sauber ist und vor allem
töpfe und pfannen und das weitere
geschehen nicht zerkratzt und das habe
ich jetzt hier auch schon mit dem
mobilie einteilern einfach aufgeteilt
alles hat seinen platz und ich hoffe
auch dass die ordnung so gehalten wird
aber ich glaube wenn man da einmal sich
so ein system gemacht hat dann klappt es
echt auch ganz gut und dann komme ich
jetzt hier zum letzten schrank das ist
der apotheker und der ist auch sehr
funktional mit der kesseböhmer
einrichtung ich habe nämlich hier auch
diese verschiedenen top jahre die kann
ich herausnehmen mit zum tisch nehmen
ich habe hier einfach die dinge verstaut
die man auch mal zum frühstücken braucht
salz und pfeffer zu kochen genauso wie
backzutaten die jetzt sarah nicht so
häufig hat aber schon auch den platz
dafür natürlich benötigt
fruchtaufstriche brotaufstriche oder
eben auch knäckebrot und noch weiteres
zubehör
die kirche jetzt fertig ich bin übrigens
auch fix und fertig die letzten tage
waren echt sehr anstrengend waren fünf
richtig intensive tage von morgens bis
abends handwerker monteure techniker
elektriker ich mein ganzes team alle
haben mitgearbeitet um diesen moment
jetzt fertig zu stellen und diesen
moment zu erschaffen econ sarah sind
schon vor der haustür und warten ganz
gespannt und ich bin schon ziemlich
gespannt auf ihre reaktion und ich hoffe
dass ihnen die küche gefällt die jetzt
so geplant und eingerichtet habe drückt
mir die daumen ich hole sie
[Musik]
gut dann würde ich sagen bei drei okay
wenn ihr dürft euch ruhig und gucken und
eure neue küche bestaunen ich hoffe sie
gefällt euch 123 otto
wow
und mein gott
[Musik]
ich wusste dass ich heute werde alles
gut geschützt
ich bin absolut sprachlos ich weiß nicht
was ich sagen will das nicht so perfekt
aus ich habe mir angst irgendwann zu
lassen
kann ich ja mit zeitreisen oder
[Gelächter]
ihr habt gestrichen
[Musik]
und ihr wisst ja wir waren groß
einkaufen also war ja schon ein
riesengroßer einkaufswagen voll und ich
habe alles hier in der küche
untergekommen
wenn nicht sogar alles hier in diesem
schrank und hier habt ihr jetzt alle
vorräte drin
übersichtlicher form
ich zeige euch noch was also wenn ihr in
zukunft kocht dann müsst ihr das mit der
fernbedienung nicht mehr machen denn
dann sind kochfeld und
dunstabzugshaube da oben verbunden die
stellen sich von alleine ein aber jetzt
zum vorführen
einschalten
[Gelächter]
ich denke ich eine super ich habe also
wird alle meine erwartungen übertroffen
das ist einfach nur
eure küche ist als offiziell gekämpft
und ganz traditionell machen wir immer
ein polaroid foto
[Musik]
und wann soll ich euch jetzt
wenn die worldcom ist meine spezialität
[Musik]
die küche ist offiziell gepimpt freunde
ich glaube mit dem herz brauche ich noch
ein bisschen hilfe aber ansonsten komme
ich klar ich mache euch jetzt mal
studios mit mal so viel wie möglich da
reingeht damit auch alle was davon haben
okay kenne sind gewaschen und let's go
ich habe mir ein paar sachen hier schon
gesehen das ist hier das ist hier zur
ablage richtig der nahe so ha ha das
habe ich nie gesehen
patrick sind schon vorbereitet ich muss
man gucken wie viele sind
ich kann einfach mal
einfach rein
[Musik]
ja bin ich auch also es gibt kaum shows
in denen ich konzentriert sein musste
als jetzt gerade weil das muss ja auch
schmecken und ich muss jetzt auch
abliefern ja und dann werde ich zu den
mund zu voll nehmen sagt abliefern
jetzt richtig hunger
ja das ist jetzt nicht so mit petersilie
oder so angerichtet
seite schön gestalten also bitteschön
ihr leben so schmecken kannst du nichts
ich komme da ich putze noch ein bisschen
h ok
sarah alles richtig
lecker ich freue mich schon drauf
im gut gekocht
ich hoffe euch hat diese folge pimp my
kitchen gefallen mir hat unglaublich
viel spaß gemacht es war eine sehr große
herausforderung diese kirche zu planen
zu organisieren doch mal ganz ganz
herzlichen dank an alle partner an alle
helfer an alle handwerker die auch
spontan noch einige strom sind sarah hat
da auch noch mal ausgeholfen hat einfach
noch 23 geschickt die sie kannte denn es
ist wirklich ein riesengroßes projekt
und es war der hammer dass wir es hier
in fünf tagen überhaupt geschafft haben
diese riesen küche einzurichten ihr
wisst beim letzten mal haben wir ja
schon überrascht dieses mal eco und
seine frau sarah und beim nächsten mal
das verrate ich jetzt noch nicht nach
schaut dir einfach nächsten mal wieder
vorbei wenn es wieder heißt fiction
comic und es reicht jetzt ich komme
und er auch kameras weg und guten
appetit
gut 40
übrigens euer nachbar helly ist ziemlich
cool
hat ihr für euch gesungen
[Musik]
habt ihr mein einer diktatur eigentlich
schocks sehen hier vor den hippies
kaubonbons gegessen und ich hab jetzt
hier ein hübsches kaubonbons
naturschutz keine produktplatzierung
aber ich hab's vergessen ich hab's
vergessen abzukoppeln aber ich find's
schön ja wenn wir gleichviel cool
bleiben wie lang acht metern vollkommen
falsch noch
nie was gehört daneben
22 meter tatsächlich
die männchen aber nur die weibchen 16 24
größere weibchen als männchen in
waghäusel
[Gelächter]
ich brauchen katzen hat noch mal einen
klaps und sarah
kannst du einmal klatschen für die
kamera die klappe
dritte geht
kannst du machen willst platini
am ende
[Musik]
fünfter sechster
siebzehnte gilt
die pflanze bringt nun richtig schön gut
deswegen habe ich sie gekauft
schöne
schönen trainiert taille was will man
mehr
[Gelächter]
ich kenne so dennler hart
und will man musste immer sinnvoll
[Musik]
ist mein ganz schnell
mit
ich
nicht
[Musik]
einzig
einmalig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wow
wow das ist herr li und harry ist ecos
zukünftiger nach war und ist der
wahnsinn es tenor opernsänger
ein bedürfnis sagen wie die werbung für
die medien machen
das war der hammer ich war übrigens ich
habe es noch nie leisten noch nie live
gehört
was für eine stimme aus so einem kleinen
menschen der so groß ist wie ich
erleben wie 2 geht es nach köln auf die
straße und wenn dann richtig mal geld
kassieren jetzt gibt es da mal ein duett
mit dir und eco
hammer danke größere nachbar ist muss
ich sagen berlin ihr habt die ganze die
ganze garage gefliest lebe ja auch keine
chancen richtig guter nachhaltig nach
gott ja richtig ist und er hilft uns
auch die ganze zeit immer wenn wir es
brauchen wir können ja nicht so econ
sarah die wenn ihr überrascht dann gehen
wir einfach zu haerlin er ist immer da
für uns
ja die ganzen leute sind da
ach schön danke
wahnsinn
die
soho house 1000 steht ja auch nicht ohne
eigentlich
abend wenig war
wenig zu solide
doch am abend wenn ich schwach
was man sich auf vorrat gut
ja
ja und genehmigt sie ist wunderschön
[Gelächter]
wir waren
größte tier der erde kann über 33 meter
lang hören da kenne ich auch leute die
so groß sind dirk nowitzki zum beispiel
der riese ernährt sich
erstaunlicherweise von winzigen
krebstieren kein veganer bin ich raus
wer sich das nächste mal
[Musik]
muss ich das eigentlich als
produktplatzierung kennzeichne oder nee
oder ich keine schleichwerbung oder
oder
was meint ihr oder ok
jetzt bin ich doch in blumen typ
passt zu dir bloß schön ok
nehmen wir aber
süße hätte ich gehe tage hinein gruppen
aber widerrief ich fahre meistens
einfach nur den wagen